[Music]
hello
party people welcome to another exciting
episode of honest trailer commentaries
today's movie is
scream ooh we feel that little chill in
the air in l.a it just dipped below 80
for the first time in months
and it's time to get halloweeny uh with
my favorite halloweenies lon harris
joestar thank you for joining me
of course time to go back to woodsboro
back to woodsboro going going backpack
uh if you haven't seen the show before
we're going to talk about the honest
trailer for scream which you should
probably watch first
uh our behind the scenes go into a
little more depth in detail about what
we thought about the movie and
afterwards we'll play some deleted
scenes
then we'll respond to comments uh from
the video itself and from in the chat
to one of these directions of my face uh
write questions in that chat
and then we will uh tease you with what
next week's honest trailer is going to
be
uh but this week it's scream and i
rewrote scream for the first time in
i don't know i watch it pretty regularly
it's like one of my favorite horror
movies
it's really good holds up yeah it's very
fun
the first one in particular they're all
pretty good
they're pretty good but the first one in
particular is really great
yeah look uh hot take here guys but uh i
like this movie a lot
and i watch it annually and uh
it's very good yes um
[Music]
and see ya see you next week end of
commentary
well why is it great uh i like it a lot
because um
it's uh when you kind of exhaust the
possibilities of a genre
that's when i think you need to go meta
um and in this movie's case going meta
um adds a layer of realism
uh to me that that other slasher movies
don't have because
it's a slasher movie in a world where
slasher movies exist which
what which is what would happen if there
was one right in my room right now
it would be like oh this is just like
that movie yeah i mean
every friday the 13th movie opens with
the kids going to camp
there's like don't go to camp look
they'll kill you
they're like and like right in our world
you'd be like maybe we shouldn't go
because that's what happens in every
movie when the kids go to a place called
camp blood
uh right so yeah like you you don't have
to do that thing where you remove
awareness of don't go into a horror
movie type
situation i also think it works well
because it's not
just a parody like it also is a slasher
movie being made by
one of the originators of the genre who
really gets
how they actually work so it's doing
both and i think that's why it holds up
so well it's it is a bonafide horror
movie that just works as a horror movie
even without the jokes the interesting
thing to me too about the parody aspect
of it
is it it fascinates me too that when
they were making it they were like no no
sell it
sell the script and sell the cuts as a
comedy
to the studio and to whoever i was like
tell them it's a comedy and they'll and
they'll get it
and i've never like yet it's meta
but i've never like seen this movie
really as uh
a satire or a parody and that i think
that's the
the mastery of like the balance that he
takes because it's
meta but it's not like um i don't know
deadpool like nudge at the fourth wall
i mean i think that horror and comedy
have have so much
in common um namely that like for both
of them to work
you need the element of surprise like
for for a joke or for
a scare it needs to be something you
didn't see coming
and what and in a horror movie when
they're like
yeah we know you've seen all these
horror movies we know what you think is
going to happen
that ratchets up the the intensity and
the possibility for scares because it's
like oh they're on to us
they they they know exactly the medium
that they're working in so i'm not going
to get the same thing that i expect as a
as a person who's seen a million horror
movies yeah so
right i think i think a lot of that is
it's like the fidelity to the
to the genre it's like not treating it
as something silly to goof on
but taking it really seriously and
trying as best they can to like
recreate it like i think that's what
works so well about you know like what
lonely island does or like what
mel brooks does in young frankenstein
like the parody works so well because
it's immediately recognizable like
this is exactly what a slasher movie is
like
so that the jokes really hit because we
immediately have that shock of
recognition
yeah um so you scream i scream we all
scream for scream scream uh let's watch
y'all's trailer for scream and see how
we managed to ring some jokes out of
this already
funny and really good movie hit it
oh pause um if you guys don't feel up to
the task we could just talk about the uh
jujitsu movie trailer that joe sent
before the show where nick cage and tony
jaw fight a jiu-jitsu predator in the
job yeah i believe frank gorilla
is in the mix as well
you got look i would nev i would not
normally say click out of this video
and go watch another video but in this
case i think it's important that you
just bail and go
the movie is called jiu jitsu uh what
happens is once every cycle
of the moon or whatever an alien
beast earth who knows uh jujitsu i guess
does he or does he demand uh he fights
somebody
yeah it seems like it's like a predator
like the alien is
challenging humanity to like show me
what you got
but like in fighting instead of music uh
and then yeah we send tony and nicholas
cage for some reason
they are they're our avatars all right
oh okay anyways back to scream uh
welcome back to this video let's go
watch scream
molten we cannot hear yes for what it's
worth and i cannot hear the video
so jiu-jitsu right uh they're in like
the jungle because when you're fighting
a predator
that's where you go yep
i mean okay oh okay we're ready all
right fine
back to scream
from the man whose mere name conjures up
visions of horror
except for that one meryl streep movie
he made
[Music]
comes the maestro's meta deconstruction
of the horror genre
there was no movie there was only
her life uh the maestro's second meta
deconstruction of the horror genre
the good one scream
people really stand up for for a new
nightmare i remember the tone being
off in a way that screen wasn't like the
scream the balance was off
um but hey you do you
well i mean i think he had the oh go
ahead i was just gonna say it's hard to
pull off
the um i don't know the the
crazed script met i don't know
it's like uh carpenter did it within the
mouth of madness uh
to some degree of success i don't know
uh
and nightmare hey well new nightmare
look okay here's my hot deck i don't
love uh freddy movies
a whole lot um so a meta deconstruction
of of a freddy movie not not necessarily
my cup of tea so i'm not
unbiased but i think i think that's kind
of what i was gonna say like i think
that movie
i like new nightmare but i do think he
has the difficulty of balancing like it
does have to be a nightmare on elm
street sequel
and he wants to sort of play these games
and like wink at the audience and make
it a deconstruction
whereas i think screen he gets to
because it's its own
new concept he gets to really do it the
way he wanted to do it and it feels
like a fresher take but i i do like both
moves
ready also in agreement with the studio
uh just going back to the earlier movie
um
had his name uh not taken off but
completely minimized in music of the
heart because when you see wes craven
you expect a certain thing so i imagine
horror fans walking into that movie
oh and straight up murder all these kids
she's gonna kill these kids
i would love that movie if meryl streep
played like a disaffected middle school
music teacher
that started slaughtering her students
like that movie's
that movie's dope yeah gold cherry gold
gary all right let's keep going
[Music]
return to a simpler time when people
left all of their doors unlocked
[Music]
no one had cell phones what are you
doing with the cellular telephones huh
true crime podcasts were books your
mother's murder was last year's hottest
court case
somebody was gonna write a book about it
and without twitter movie dorks had to
get creative when it came to harassing
women
what's your favorite scary movie uh i
don't know
jason's mother mrs voorhees was the
original killer wrong
answer if this movie were made today
the mask would be an anime avatar meet
sydney
the version uh i guess i don't have
anything to add to that
joe
true i know a lot of people probably get
mad about it in the comments and go oh
you're probably thinking but it's a
funny joke so like do you like scary
movies
name your eight favorites don't suck
me debate would have been the
catchphrase
yeah well we'll see scream five uh
around the corner
yeah um all right keep going
meet sydney the virginist virgin whoever
virgined i thought maybe we could do a
little on top of the clothes stuff
but this sweet innocent girl is cursed
with the worst social group
of all time there's tantas i mean tatum
who's more concerned with partying than
helping her friend promptu party tonight
my house are you serious come on sir
for me who is dealing with way scarier
stuff off camera than on
billy a big johnny depp enthusiast this
green junkies fan
obviously they don't watch enough movies
this is standard horror movie stuff
there's a formula to it a very simple
formula
this card you worked at a video store
right right lon
yes yes many years yeah didn't you joe
yeah for a minute but i i probably don't
have lawns tails
yeah i worked at like a weird la
indie video store not like a suburban
black yeah no i worked at a blockbuster
in the middle of kentucky the most thing
that happened to me was wondering why
four brothers was so popular for so long
i did like a few weeks in a blockbuster
but i
not not for any length of time but yeah
for many years i worked at like a weird
like former laserdisc
store that had turned into a a dvd
well there you go so yes i think that's
this screen junkies fan tracks
yeah we'd have a guy who he there was a
guy who come in and he had a list of
every vampire movie ever made it was
long and he was going alphabetically one
by one looking to watch
every single one those are that was like
a typical day in my
video career i did i uh
it doesn't quite count but i did work at
a record store for a long time where
before
uh saint anger came out metallica's
saint anger
every day for like two months and he was
like a wayne's world extra like
he looked like a roadie at wayne stock
and uh
would come in every day um this was in
the panhandle of florida so he's real
um coming every day asked about st anger
we'd be like nope not today man and he'd
be like
all good bro and then get in his camaro
and leave
you tell him like there was a release
date like you would be like not until
july 17th man told him a lot
around my neck uh
that's all i remember from that album
yeah um but good for that all right
keep going oh formula this clocks when i
say hurry
please interpret that as move your fat
tub of lard ass
now and stew a guy who does some of the
most upsetting mouth stuff and horror
since ichi the killer
it was fun never alone
yeah welcome to think of it everyone at
this school is a monster
it's just a personal thing of mine i
just find matthew lillard's mouth so
upsetting
just the thing he's the stuff he's doing
with it that whole movie everything is
all like
yeah there's so much of it it's it's
it's that
it's not that a little bit of it
wouldn't be fine it's just it's like
every scene he's doing
some of them seem like some of them
you're like okay he just
does mouth stuff but some of them still
choreographed that he had to practice in
front of a mirror just like
tongue like really
it's not it's not just like a matthew
lillard that like he doesn't do that in
other movies he like specifically like
it's a choice
this is what stu would do yeah doesn't
do that as shaggy
no he does it he's not doing that as
shaggy all the time that's like
he's made a decision for this character
uh gave me the heebie-jeebies i don't i
do not like that
that's my least favorite part of the a
lot of people while it's doing this and
tasting confused like you're making a
choice
i think matthew lillard kind of like
became the under the radar like
96 symbol because of this movie and the
upsetting mouth stuff oh cause it's a
large tongue
yeah yeah it was this slc punk
one of those two yep him and dex shepard
who
what what is their deal with the devil
what's going on
anyways keep going
alone yeah
you know come to think of it everyone at
this school is a monster
fairness would be to rip your insides
out they found principal hymn regatted
and hung from the goal post
let's go over there before they bring
him down hey
except the cop weirdly he's the only
cool one you're underage son
i'm kidding have a good time suit up
with a slasher
who's all killer no filler because while
some horror icons spend their time
talking trash
or doing spooky vanishing acts
[Music]
this ghostface killer just bought the
first mask they saw on the way to school
they sell this costume every five and
dime in the state giving you no
safe spaces as he stalks you all over
town
from the shrubbery outside of your own
house to the ladies room
to the grocery store in broad daylight
uh we have a slasher now for
and busts into every fight night first
without a plan beyond stabby stabby
you gotta respect the hustle even if
everyone is constantly beating the crap
out of him
[Music]
all right boss we tried this with um
jackass music uh it didn't quite as well
the original music queue uh was the one
that we use in the revenant honest
trailer like vince and jackass sound
alike and that one is great but i guess
we use a different sound library now so
benny hill it was um i think jackass
music
and benny hill music are are tied to me
for making people falling down funnier
[Laughter]
betty hill is the the classic like when
you want to nod to like the greats
of the genre that's betty hill i think
like jackass is like a fun modern
alternative
spit up but yeah but anyways we're
talking about
i guess ghost face as a as a slasher as
an eyebrow
um i don't know like all he's got going
for him is that there's spoiler alert
more than one of him um i thought it was
really cool how they
actually yeah they they uh um
they kind of telegraphed that i i i
picked that up this time of the
the two ghost face who run through the
halls that henry winkler like
uh suspends it's like two people wearing
the costume right
oh they're kind of kind of planting the
seed right there
my favorite thing in this re-watch was
uh how hard
uh matthew lillard's character is trying
to spoil the movie like right out the
gate
well i think that the whole thing like
they they really hit home
uh like billy is a killer like
over and over and over again and then
they try to like pull that back but like
when he
comes into the room they start playing
don't fear the reaper like
[Laughter]
it's not subtle that they want you to
think that billy is a killer
yeah i do respect ghost faces
hustle like like there's something to be
said about a fast-moving
slasher it's like a running zombie like
i i appreciate a slasher that runs at
you like the
uh same with um happy death day like
when he actually just starts hauling ass
after her down the
down that parking garage the first time
like that's a scary scary shot and happy
death day i i find a a man who runs at
you with a knife scarier than a jason
who
slowly shambles with another yeah
yeah i mean it's it's nice to take a
breather from the like lumbering like i
feel like you know like
so many films of this genre it's like
that the
lumbering it's like it's scary because
it's methodical like
he never gives up he's just always after
you but uh yeah
in the immediate sense in terms of like
as an action
film like the kills in scream are a lot
more like exciting than a lot of these
other movies
because he's like roughly physically
capable it's like a young guy who can
actually come out
yeah it's definitely by design like i
think wes craven definitely looked at
the slasher genre and was like what
needs to change in this movie like what
do we kind of need to comment on
in this movie and making them
not unstoppable like you know undead
druid powered you know whatever
it it changes the dynamics of the
choreography of the tension of the pace
yeah it's also i mean that is also a
freddy thing is he's a lot more
act like physically active as a menace
that a lot of the typical slasher like
that's definitely something less craven
sort of leads into
now i've always uh uh wondered so
wu-tang comes out you know 1994
something like that like and enter the
wu tang early 90s
you have ghost face killer 36 36 36
chambers yeah you have ghost face killer
and then
ghostface a killer comes along in scream
uh
96. is this why ghostface uh killa
became
pretty tony or tony starks was he was
there a copyright battle over there i
mean
ghostface killer the rapper definitely
selected his name
prior to scream like many years prior i
would think for the formation of a
wu-tang from a 79 film called mystery of
chess boxing
right but i mean like but the wu-tang
clan would have formed well
before scream was even a twinkle in
kevin williamson's eye i'm just
wondering if he if he
became if he was worried about confusion
that he started referring to himself as
perhaps the wallaby champion
he's the origin of right tony starks or
whatever uh
perhaps it was less copyright concern
and more just eventually
you just start adding nicknames like odb
was big baby jesus
and ghostface became tony starks
well there you go and then tony starks
came along and then yeah
did they start calling the killer adding
titles
did they start calling the slasher and
scream ghostface as a nod to the wu-tang
clan that's with the question
i think it's literally what the mask was
called because oh that was the ghost
face
it goes face mask yeah oh i see that
makes it interesting
all right well the more you know keep
going
[Music]
so heat up some jiffy pop and revisit
the classic that's packed full of nods
to other horror movies
would you call me not your friend
and when they can't think of a nod they
just say the name of a horror movie you
like out loud
the exorcist was on it it's the town
that dreaded sundown
how many hellraisers nightmare down the
street silence of the lambs
terra train the howling psycho friday
the 13th
prom like candyman halloween and what
movie is this from i spit on your garage
in this innovative slasher that rescued
a genre that was drowning in bad sequels
and remakes
only to eventually drown in its own
sequels and remakes
but still it not only saved horror at
the time it managed to kill off the
spoof movie too
do you like spoofy movies you should see
how we pee
not anymore story
yeah i guess scream led to
what would then go on to ruin the spoof
movie
yes right screams
scary movie which then begat all of
those hearts superhero movie
movie right there what are those guys
names
yeah i don't know the zucker oh no no
there are two guys who worked on scary
movie who then the wayans threw away
everything they wrote but those were the
two guys that ended up doing all these
other
yeah the only thing i remember about the
spartans yeah like
at some point after meet the spartans
came out like um
you know how like the trades
you know how like the trades are like
movie news tv news
and also what actors are selling their
house
uh for some reason uh after meet the
spartans came out there was like he like
sold his home and it was just this giant
beautiful
thing built with money from meet the
spartans so proud of him
very great job remembering gangnam style
well done
sir really now you guys know how you
nailed that reference to that thing
people liked
four years ago someone's got to do it
yeah this definitely do they
do they spencer do they
someone's going because they have to
they don't have to
okay but yeah this uh scary movie
definitely
uh was the first domino in in
killing what gave us naked gun and
national lampoon's loaded weapon one and
interestingly those guys actually they
started off
as the writers of spy heart the leslie
nielsen one so they like
it really is like a generational shift
like they came in at the tail end of
these zucker abrams
era and then pivoted it in this horrible
new direction
god can we take that crown already can
we kill them and take their
take their jobs is that how it works
that's how it works in hollywood right
why
why are we writing the out of step
parodies of stuff that was popular four
years ago
yeah i wanna uh i wanna make iron man do
the whop dance
don't give up
that'll be 10 million oh my god that's
gold
okay let's finish this up ring i know
who your mom did last summer never been
killed
i'll be there for you when the blood
starts to pour
oh skeet skeet mr ulrich in the garage
i feel safe mountain dewey
like zoinks am i a ghost face
slice principles and mark wahlberg talks
to animals
say hello to your mother okay donkey
hey guys look we did it we referenced
the thing that was funny for us what
they were actually going to call it
boom sorry this is really the scariest
part of the movie
this cheerleader who takes a dumb then
sticks her finger in her mouth
without washing her hands disgusting
yeah they really did that stunt for the
movie that's not a stunt person at all
and she took a real dump every take
right david fincher styles yeah she had
to
wes craven the perfectionist um there's
only
one thing i think that i didn't bother
to put in the script that i noticed
which was that
everyone's wearing uh like knit t-shirts
which i found to be kind of odd in the
summer like all their billy's shirts and
and sydney's and stuff like that
they're all short sleeve but they're
like a chunky material
uh which is like when it's fall but you
don't want to commit
no one owns a regular t-shirt in this
movie maybe it's like for better
stabbing like it absorbs the blood
better when you get stabbed
so it was a creative choice no anyways
it just hit the clearance rack at like
pacific sun where
yeah or i mean it could be to suggest
like new school year
fall back to school like maybe it was a
purposeful like visual choice
right they brought but it's hot outside
um but it was like very sunny
because they were they were shooting or
whatever well there you go that was
not worthy of even being written down
but let's see what we wrote down and
then ended up cutting let's play those
outtakes
and without twitter movie dorks had to
get creative when it came to harassing
women
what's your favorite scary movie uh i
don't know
jason's mother mrs boris was the
original killer
wrong answer
friday the 13th is better than nightmare
on elm street prove me wrong
debate me being extra mean to prove
she's not just a sitcom actress
when i say hurry please interpret that
as move your fat
tub of lard ass now except the cop
weirdly he's the only cool one
you're underage son i'm kidding
have a good time and that dude is nuts
[Music]
um david arquette is i think it's
invincible
uh or david arquette's indestructible
let me look up the dock basically yeah
he's decided that he wants to do death
match
pro wrestling and it's a it's a wild
ride
well he did that movie one ready to
rumble and he like trained to do
wrestling to be in the movie and he just
became like fascinated
and obsessed with it yeah yeah uh but
yeah it's a it's a wild ride just
watching him pull like tacks and bits of
pvc pipe
or uh out of his body while his wife
just pretends to be as supportive as
possible like i'm so glad you made this
choice
yeah it's a wild dog wow and this is
where the
the arquette cox romance bloomed right
on
the set of scream yeah right yeah um
wow all right uh
what else we got
and bust into every fight night first
without a plan beyond stabby stabby
just one weakness when you're a killer
who's only inspired by horror movies you
gotta mix in some crime procedurals
fingerprints you dorks pack so full of
self-awareness
it's shocking no one broke the fourth
wall june
look behind turn around behind you
could you be anymore in scream he's just
a skeeter boy
hey you guys remember the movie doom
generation that movie is weird
do lives matter rookie doo
officer on duty howdy dewey
stuart slays his family and we all love
you henry winkler
watch a few movies take a few notes i'm
just glad these lunatics never saw joker
oh god yeah
i was thinking my favorite um
[Music]
actual well my other favorite meta
horror movie that breaks the fourth wall
is uh funny games um yeah which is
like scream if it were genuinely
disturbing and like admonishing you for
watching a horror movie in the first
place it's
right it's very bad yeah in a good way
designed to make you
actually feel bad about watching the
movie you're watching
yeah which is always great but thank you
guys you should feel good for watching
this show
yeah please subscribe if you haven't
already and
uh hit that like button and hit that
bell so that you don't miss
another video which we make
semi-regularly um
use that those are the outtakes uh what
else do we have i think we have some
comments from you guys
uh let's see what we do feedback always
chris a wrote the clue last week was we
won't be monkeying around next week i
don't get it how's that a clue for
scream
ah well i see you're not a fellow man of
culture like myself uh i said it was
monk monkeying around edvard monk the
painter
famously painter of the scream uh
and yeah you obviously should have
that's a very national treasure
monk edward monk the scream they're
doing scream yeah yeah
yeah so yeah gotta keep it up
you had to be kind of batman and robin
to put that one together yeah you could
have definitely been on for at least
three weeks to be like
the museum has an edvard monk uh guild
collection going up this friday
good point boy wonder
uh do we really need rob filkins asked
do we really need a scream
five though no do we need one i mean wes
we don't have west craven anymore
obviously
uh but i think there's more
semi-meta horror comedies that are also
scary
movies to be made and uh i'll give him
this one let's see where this one goes
then
then we'll make that judgment what do
you guys have i mean i think with screen
you've got a lot of leeway
one because anytime you're doing another
sequel you can say like well
but that's it's a parody of horror
franchises that go on too long
so it kind of makes sort of an intuitive
sense and i think that yeah with every
especially if it's been a long time
since the last screen movie
you can always update the new movie
because you've got new horror movies to
like comment on
so yeah i mean i think we were i think
we talked about this before
like i think a scream take on like a 24
20 20 era like elevated horror would be
really fun and like that's a thing that
wasn't really
around when they made stream three
screen four so it's sort of a fresh
thing for them to take on like a slasher
who's actively trying to make you
understand that he's a metaphor for
depression
right like like uh like a play on you
know like the witch or
like midsomar or like that kind of a
horror movie that's so popular now
but wasn't around when stream was a
thing
yeah totally um ben zeitung writes was
there an allen in the honest trailer i
don't know
there usually is kevin's been slipping
them in so consistently i don't even ask
i just
assume that he's put it in there so yeah
i'll admit that kevin usually tells us
where they are so i don't
bother to like really scan and look for
them because yeah like he's gonna email
and tell me where to look but he didn't
this time look please
let us know if he did or if he skipped
it we'll have to have multiple allens
the next day i'm going to confirm that
it's definitely there and you should
just keep rewatching the video until you
find it it's very good
yeah even better tell us where it is uh
micah simpson asked what was the first
movie you remember being scared by
well i've told this story before mine
was definitely ransom that my parents
took me to see
ransom in theaters i don't know why
it's not a horror movie but it was about
a kidnap boy about my age
uh and they decided that that would be
the film to take me to
um so let me think of my first horror
movie while you guys answer yeah
i only watched comedies for like my
whole life and then i went to a
sleepover and we watched
child's play and i got really freaked
out because it was like
it was literally the first movie that
was even trying to scare you that i
watched
oh wow i saw um
the nest uh way too young it's like a
cheesy
maybe late 70s early 80s i can't
remember the year exactly
it was about uh cockroaches that that
kill people
and uh there's a scene where um it's
been a while but
this lady thinks her dad died and he
like comes into the room
and she's like oh my god dad and they
embrace and you realize lots of roaches
have just put his skin on
well uh yeah that's that's stayed here
for a while yeah that sounds creepy yeah
that and garbage spell kids
yeah that was definitely like unsettling
i don't know if it went full and it's
like scared but definitely creepy and
and problematic yeah um
i guess uh the first story i started
with the best i watched the shining very
early on
and kept my eyes half closed the entire
time as a as a young kid
uh so off to a good start um but yeah
child's play freaked the hell out of me
oh my god yeah
i was like i think it blows you in
because
it's like it doesn't seem like it's
gonna be that scary it's like you know
there's a kid in this it's about toys
like i get that the toy turns evil but
i was not expecting to be so freaked out
by the end of that
yes um all right final question you can
give a one-word answer
uh levetto writes uh should we do it
should we get a scooby-doo
gory slash creepy franchise the gory
creepy update to scooby-doo
no is my answer i mean i would say no if
only because to
to keep it consistent with scooby-doo it
can't be supernatural like it would have
to be just like a murderer
like it's an old man actually killing
people which doesn't sound like that
i'll say that uh i if uh if they're
gonna do anything else post venture
brothers that's what i want to see the
venture
doc hammer and jackson public hit next
is the scooby doo
style genre teen detectives in a
there is a scooby-doo group in the
venture brothers
verse right there is i'm pretty sure i'm
gonna be honest once it got like two
years between seasons i i dropped off so
i'm there there are
two like teen hippie detectives in the
venture brothers that are like a
scooby-doo
yeah the groovy gang i thought the
griffin
yeah mentally disturbed amateur
detectives that solve mysteries that may
or may not exist
exactly god bless that show perfect so
good so yeah groovy is the name of their
great dane
who comes along with that i would watch
that spin off
um all right that's all for this week uh
we're keeping the horror theme going
next week uh where you might get two
horror movies in one i'll just say that
um
that's your clue for next week uh please
enjoy
then and i hope you enjoyed today on
this week's episode of vonn's trail
commentaries joe long thank you thank
you guys for watching like subscribe
do the thing see you next week bye
[Music]
you